Det är Milan till exempel, som fotbollsklubben.
Jag älskar att du förklarar, om någon lyssnar på den här fucking podden och inte vet vad Milan betyder när du säger Milan, då måste vi förklara att det är en fotbollsklubb.
Till och med jag som inte ens tittar på fotboll vet.
Ringde mina kollegor, vi ska starta en podd nu.
Löste, vi börjar spela in på måndag.
Jag ska ringa Aftonbladet sen.
Jag ska hitta på ett namn på podden.
Behövs det verkligen ett tydligt intervju?
Är det den bästa idéen vi har?
Inte den sämsta idéen vi har, men inte den sämsta idéen vi har.
Exakt, exakt.
Det kan bli bra.
Det kan bli hyggligt.
Det kör vi på.
Det får det bli.
Klart, då går vi vidare.
Då säger vi välkommen till podden Lucas från Flow Life.
Stort tack och kul att vara här.
Ja, väldigt roligt.
Eller det är jag som är hos er.
Jag är på er huvudkontor.
Jag gissar att detta är.
Stämmer, stämmer.
Ja, det är kul att du är här och kul att jag får vara med i podden.
Exakt, jag gick upp 0-2-30 i morse, tog tåget hit, drick 8 koffer kaffe och kände mig pig.
Ja, tur att vi har en stor kanna framför oss.
Jag stötte på en av dina, är det en medgrundare eller en kollega som jag hälsade på först här?
En kollega, vår head of Icom.
Ja, han har bott grannen med mig och den enda historien jag kunde om honom var att någon i hans bekantskopskrets somnade i duschen och räddningstjänsten stod där och det var när du var iväg och hämtade någonting.
Men då sa han att jag har bott grannen med dig och det enda minnet jag har av det är att räddningstjänsten stod och knackade på min dörr en dag för att det läckte vatten ner i någon annans lägenhet.
Oj, så om du har lite sömnbrist idag ska vi hålla extra koll på toaletten då det blir för många besök.
Exakt, om jag ska jävlas tillbaka.
Men i alla fall, jag tänker du har redan berättat din historia ganska många gånger.
Jag är mest intresserad idag, kanske mer av er att bolag och hur utvecklingen har gått och hur ni har fokuserat för att kunna växa så pass fort.
Det har ju ändå varit en, om man komprimerar de här fem åren så är det ju en extrem resa som har hänt under de här fem åren i utvecklingstakt, så det är lite det jag vill fokusera på.
Men om vi gör en liten kort, kort, kort intro om vem du är.
Super, kul.
Jättebra fokus, det har ju hänt mycket de senaste åren.
Jag heter Lucas Waschnewski då, medgrundare, en av fyra, och vd på Flowlife.
Och brinner väl för att nå min fulla potential och skapa saker som kan nå sin fulla potential.
Oavsett om det är jobbmässigt, träningsmässigt eller på alla andra vis.
Och det är det jag gör med Flowlife också.
Vi tar ju fram återhämtningsprodukter, vi blev väldigt kända för vår massagepistol när den kom, flowgan.
För ni var typ först?
Ja, vi var väldigt tidiga.
Det fanns den typen av produktlinjer med mycket ombyggda andra produkter eller saker som lät så mycket att det knappt gick att använda.
Så vi fick den här slagtekniken då tillgänglig med flowgan.
Och sen det första vi gjorde som vi också kände för var i vår, vi tog fram den första sladdlösa massagekudden som fanns i världen.
För det är den jag känner er ifrån, eller det är den jag har sett.
Men då var det oldschool, då var det äkta.
Den var först, det var inte massagekudden?
Den var först och den är fortfarande en av våra stor säljare.
Det är en produkt vi har vidutvecklat så länge.
Det började egentligen med att vi pluggade.
Vi fyra grundare har jobbat tillsammans tidigare.
Vi har haft säljkonsultbolag, gjort små projekt när vi var i skolan, vi var på våra första två jobb tillsammans.
Sen åkte vi alla runt i Sverige och började plugga.
Jag var nere i Göteborg och pluggade på Chalmers.
De andra var här uppe i Stockholm.
Vi brukade se så vi alltid gillat affärer och göra saker och produkter.
En dag när jag hälsade på min mamma så hade hon en sån här stor jobbig massageprodukt och den hade en sladd.
Varje gång hon tvungde använda den tvungde hon flytta på soffan.
Då byggde vi ihop en egen massagekudde som var uppladdningsbar.
Det var egentligen så det började.
Sen tog vi med den till Lidinge Loppet.
Märkte massagetränning, kul.
Sedan dess har vi jobbat stenhårt med att koppla ihop just massaget och ett aktivt liv.
Och vad det kan möjliggöra.
Men är ni någon sorts, vad ska vi kalla det?
Är er bakgrund inom träning, massage, rehab?
Alla vi har ju...
Chalmers är ju inte hårdförknippat med...
Fysiskt, nej nej nej, det är inte liksom fysiskt.
Nej, det är kanske inte det.
Alla vi har ju hållit på med sport, olika sporter.
Flera av oss kanske har trott att vi kanske är bättre än vad vi är och att vi ska komma någonstans.
Man har ju haft de här drömmarna och det är ju därför det är så kul att jobba mot den delen också.
Men jag tror framför allt att alla vi brinner för ett aktivt liv.
Oavsett nivå.
Sen är det olika om man i olika perioder satsar man olika mycket och på olika delar.
Vi gillar att testa saker och alltid hitta något att utmana sig.
Min senaste hang-up är ju löpning nu så att jag sprang mitt första maraton förra året.
Fy fan.
Det var en upplevelse.
Vad var tiden får man fråga?
Ja den var lugn, det var strax över fem timmar.
Så jag hade inte bråttom kan jag säga.
Okej, men det är väl bra med deltagande.
Ja tack, tack.
Jag kan säga så här, jag kommer ju hem till Sverige nu och jag har inte varit så sugen på att springa utomhus.
Nu är det mer in i gymmet.
Har du samma problem som jag har för att på Gymmkompaniet är det ju så att jag är överlägset i sämst form på bolaget.
Känner du också att alla dina kollegor är lite bättre?
Eller har du ändå några du kan spöa om du vill?
Det är ju olika grenar, man får välja sina fighter.
Det är det som är så fantastiskt med träning.
Tumbrottning är okej.
Man blir bra på det man tränar för, men det är ju kul, jag har en kollega som är ultralöpare och som ska ut och köra och han bor någon mil ifrån mig och jag laddar hela söndagen för att springa ett halvmaraton tillsammans med honom.
Han kommer ju springande hem till mig såklart.
Och sen så springer han runt med mig och tänker jag ska nog springa hem, jag ska bara köpa en cola.
Och sen springer han tillbaka.
Då blir man lite såhär, ja det gjorde du enkelt.
Nej men sen är det ju, alla vi tränar ju, och alla vi tränar olika saker.
Nu är det ju, nu är det mycket gym den här tiden på året, det är inte jättekul att träna ut det.
Men vi försöker hålla igång tillsammans.
Jag förstår.
Men den stora passionen ligger i företaget och företagandet kanske?
Jag har förmånen att träffa och lära känna många väldigt duktiga atleter, och jag tycker nog det sättet jag kan identifiera mig mest med dem är ju inte min fysiska förmåga, för där är de på en annan nivå.
Men det är ju kanske den dedicationen man har till någonting.
Jag försöker se företagandet i jobbet som en sport, där man jobbar så hårt man kan, sen återhämtar man sig så väl man kan och inne i det.
Och jag tror att det på senare år har verkligen kommit in i ens livsstil, att på helgerna så är det ett annat tempo, man vill komma ut i naturen, man vill göra saker som återhämtar sig.
Gör du det på riktigt eller är det en sån här?
Jag tycker att alla såna här poddar säger alltid entreprenörerna att vad gör du på fritiden?
Jag går ut i naturen.
Vem?
Och alla poddar är alltid i Stockholm.
Var någonstans här går ni ut i naturen?
Det finns ingen naturen.
Det är kul, de pratar om Haga parken då, de har två träd.
Jag bor i Solna, så jag har ändå ganska nära till Haga parken och sjöar och har föräldrar som bor en bit utanför stan som är hund.
Men du går väl inte och matar fåglar?
Nej, men det finns en liten del.
När man går runt de här två sjöarna så är det alltid massa som tar bilder på fåglar och fågelskådare.
Det är ju alltid lika intressant att fråga om var de fotar, för då får man tio minuter non stop, utläggningen så att de pekar in i vassen.
Man ser ingenting, men tydligen är det någonting väldigt sällsynt där inne.
Jag förstår, ärligt.
Det är bra att alla har olika intressen.
Ja, verkligen.
Jag tänkte att vi hoppar lite in i businessen direkt, för det är det jag tycker är mer spännande och det är det folk får lyssna på helt enkelt.
Ni har ju gjort en ganska snabb resa, jag kan inte extrakta siffror, men det känns som att ni gjorde typ en dubblering på en dubblering på en trippel ungefär.
Och som mest, som man kan se av alla bolag, så maxade ni väl ut på 74-75 miljoner?
Någonstans där.
Och ni gjorde också en investeringsrunda i den processen där ni tog in lite kapital, eller ganska mycket kapital, fast för en ganska liten del av...
Ni gjorde en väldigt fin investeringsrunda kan man säga.
Och jag har lyssnat på det i tidigare poddar och då har ni varit ganska mycket att det är ni själva som gör processen.
Ni har inte tagit in kapital utan ni är ett gäng från början som har gjort er grej, ni har jobbat med lönsamhet och ni har ju alltid varit lönsamma innan.
Hur gick tankarna i när ni tog in kapital och lite hur gick den processen till?
Det är en spännande process för när man väl drog igång den så var det verkligen som att det var verkligen att en boll började rulla och så började den rulla.
Det här var i slutet på 2021 som vi började bli uppvaktade av olika aktörer.
Vi hade väl inte haft den planen på att göra någonting.
Men efter ett tag bestämde vi oss för att det är kul att se hur långt vi kan ta det här bolaget och hur vi kan göra och vi vill gå in på fler marknader.
Vi hade ett väldigt fint läge för vi hade gjort en resa helt utan något externt kapital.
Vi hade tagit oss väldigt långt.
Vi hade också en väldigt bra produktexcellence som många gillade.
Våra produkter var väldigt bra och vi hade lyckats hitta kvalitet på dem och bra kundresunktioner.
Och slutade väl egentligen med att vi valde något vi kallar Smart Capital.
Vi valde alltså investerare som också kunde vara engagerade och som kunde bidra till vår långsiktiga resa med planen att ta in kanske mer pengar för pengarna skull senare.
Och det var ju otroligt på ett sätt för att vi hade tagit oss väldigt långt och alltid varit lönsamma.
Sedan fick man ju den här liksom, man blev nog lite indragen i det här investerarsynsättet med att ta mer risker, satsa allt, gå på många marknader samtidigt.
Var ni bara i Sverige innan?
Ja vi sålde primärt i Sverige men vi har haft lite i Danmark, vi hade varit lite i Nederländerna.
Men vi hade väl inte investerat så mycket kostnader kopplat till lanseringen.
Vi hade alltid varit väldigt effektiva på vårt sätt att jobba, alltid varit duktiga med partners och med annat.
Men när vi stängde den här lilla kapitalrundan så började vi satsa.
Det som hände då var att den här satsningen som vi gjorde på att gå in på fler marknader samtidigt inföljer ungefär samtidigt med att hela världen stannade upp, med kriget i Ryssland, med dollarpriserna som du självtäkert har fått uppleva.
Ja, frakterna som checkar upp en.
Så vi höll den satsningen under det året och sen så drog vi handbromsen och sa hallå nu måste vi gå tillbaka till hur vi var innan den här investeringen.
Och det var ju en otrolig läxa som ändå en relativt ung för entreprenör får lära sig att vara med om.
Supertuff när det händer, för att vi hade ju det synsätt att vi tog in för det vi skulle bli och sen så lyckades vi inte komma in på de nya marknaderna som vi hade önskat.
Och då fick man gå tillbaka till det steget man var.
Vilket är såklart supertufft.
Inte minst det mänskliga, vissa fick lämna som hade jobbat.
För ni gjorde en ganska stor rekrytering under den.
Ja exakt, i samband med det.
Och det var ju supertufft, jag ska vara ärlig och säga att det är det absolut tuffaste jag gjort i mitt företagsliv.
Det är också någonting som jag är otroligt ödmjuk till framåt.
Att jag tror ju väldigt mycket på en arbetskultur där man får väldigt stort ansvar och fritt spelmedel som anställd.
Men jag tror att min roll tydligare som vd kommer att hålla koll på helheten på ett sätt som jag kanske inte gjorde då.
Kan du inte spesa dig lite mer?
Jo men vi hade en organisationsform som var nära till nåt som kallas Teal Organization.
Att det var väldigt självorganiserande.
Egentligen vem som helst i organisationen fick ta vilket beslut de ville.
Och det var en stor framgång till att vi växte så fort.
För att vi hade personal som var otroligt engagerade.
Och det har vi fortfarande, vilket är superkul men det gjorde att man fick känna den här entreprenela känslan, vilken roll man ändå hade i bolaget.
När vi sen går in från en högkonjunktur i en lågkonjunktur där hela byggandet av bolaget förändras över en natt, där det går från att bara göra så mycket du kan, så snabbt du kan, överallt för att synas så mycket, till att nu måste du vara smart i dina beslut.
Du ska inte göra fel saker.
Du krävs en annan typ av tänk.
Den omställningen var väldigt svår.
Jag vet inte om du tänkte på det men det var väldigt många vd-are som fick lämna runt 2021-2022.
Just för att det är olika typer av ledarskapstil som behövs också.
Och det är en otrolig läxa man fått lära sig, att det behövs mer ekonomisk kontroll.
Vi hade investerare som var fantastiska som inte detaljstyrde oss.
Hade vi tagit andra investerare, då hade de nog fått oss att dra ner på produktkvaliteten eller göra prisjusteringar för att vi tappade extremt mycket produktmarginal egentligen bara över ett par månader.
Och det under den kortsiktiga perioden var extremt negativt.
Vi förlorade mycket pengar under det året.
Men det långsiktigt där vi är idag, där vi är ett lönsamt bolag, vi har haft snart ett år där vi har varit lönsamma och där vi ser väldigt bra ut.
Nu har vi fortfarande ett fantastiskt renommé.
Vi har jättebra recensioner överallt med kunder som vi är supernöjda.
Och jag tror inte att de märker av den skillnaden som har skett för att vi alltid varit så otroligt prioriterade med kvalitén mot kunder.
Nej, utifrån blir man ju förvånad.
Jag är jätteintresserad av företagsresor.
Jag har ju bara läst om, jag läste ju om er investeringsrunda och jag har ju hört er på poddar och sånt där.
Och sen så, jag har ju även din massagekudde där, eller vad ni kallar den, ni kallar den någonting.
Och jag har ju vänner som har det såklart och sånt där.
Men så utifrån så går man in och tittar och man tänker, ja men det har väl taktat på här liksom.
Och sen så går man in och så ser man ju den här lilla dippen då i omsättning och i resultat.
Och det märks inte alls som du säger i företaget.
Det finns ju ingen normal konsument som går in och kikar på ett.
Nej men det handlar mycket om så här, vi tappar ungefär runt 20 procent över år till år på omsättningsmässigt.
En stor anledning till det var att vi slutade med den här uppsökande försäljningen på samma sätt.
Vi gjorde extremt stora investeringar i bolaget.
Så vi fortsatte med alla de investeringar som gjorde att bolaget skulle vara skalbart långsiktigt.
Det är ju så tråkiga saker men som måste funka, typ affärssystem, bytte plattform på hemsida.
Det gjorde väldigt mycket som gjorde att bolaget skulle hitta en plats där vi kunde ta nästa steg ifrån innan vi började ta nästa steg.
Sen tror jag man måste förklara också, om man inte själv driver bolag så tror jag att det är svårt att förstå.
För när du säger att vi tappade 20% så låter inte det så mycket.
Det är ju inte så galet mycket.
Men om man är ett företag som är vant vid att växa 100% per år, och man är hela tiden van vid att anställa för att hantera nästa år, ta in system så att man ska hantera nästa år, då ligger man ju hela tiden ett år före eller två år före i den här utvecklingen.
Om man sedan inte får den tillväxten utan hamnar i ett nedåtgång, så blir det en sån extrem chock för hela organisationen hur man hanterar det.
Det är en mentalitetsförändring som måste göra.
Det går inte att sitta och låtsas som att man som bolag i Sverige inte har blivit påverkad av allt som händer konsumenten.
Alltså de extrema ränteökningarna som har gjort det som har hänt med kronan, har gjort att allt har blivit dyrare i inflationen.
Men jag tror att man får gå tillbaka när det här är tuffa tider.
Då får man gå tillbaka till grunden.
Var är som verkligen gör det?
Men kan du också ta oss igenom, för det måste ju ha varit, jag gissar att du gick igenom någon sorts process av att fan det här är ju skit.
Och sen när man ändå får någon sorts revansch, för nu har ni ändå kommit ut på andra sidan och är tillbaka i lönsamhet och växande siffror och sånt där.
Det är ju extremt många bolag som inte gör den uppsvängen, det är ju därför detta är så intressant.
Hade det bara varit en krasch här, det är ju skittråkigt.
Men om man lyckas komma igång igen, hur har tankarna och hur har organisationen gått under den vändningsresan?
Den är ju det mest utmanande.
Jag tror egentligen handlar det om en väldigt enkel sak.
Man måste se verkligheten för vad det är, man måste agera rejält och snabbt på den och anpassa sig efter den.
Och sen efter dess får man hitta sina inre drivkrafter, både som organisation och också hitta de personer som faktiskt brinner för det vi gör som helhet.
Och jag skulle säga att vi är ett mycket mindre team än vi var förut, vi är ungefär under hälften så många.
Men vi har ett engagemang och en output från oss som är enorm, så stor som det aldrig har varit.
För att när vi kommer, när man är inne i en hög period, då jobbar man på hela tiden, man bygger på någonting som tidigare funnits.
När man är i en period där man får backa tillbaka, då startar man om processer och gör om det från början.
Och att få den här reflektionen som den perioden ger, även fast den är väldigt tuff att ha mycket, den gör att man sedan kan starta om och börja bygga upp från en ny platå, som är mycket högre än vad de förra startade och med bättre potential.
Men det är ju någonting som, jag tror ju väldigt mycket på en nära arbetskultur, och för att säga upp anställningar av folk som man på riktigt verkligen tycker om, är ju bland det tuffaste man kan göra.
Men det är ju lite som att man sitter, man satt ju i en båt som hade växt väldigt snabbt i ett plats för mer, tagit in fler personer, sen kom vi in i en period där man såg framför sig att nu kommer världen att tuffa dig ett, två år, och båten kommer krympa.
Och antingen skulle vi alla sjunka tillsammans, eller så får man se till att några hittar andra båten och kan hoppa till.
Och överlag så tror jag att den ena anledningen att det gick bra ändå var att vi var väldigt transparenta med vad som skett där.
Vi visade siffror, vi visade omvärlden, visade vad vi trodde.
Och jag skulle säga att folk förstod till en väldigt hög grad, för att om man är ärlig mot folk och är transparent, då är folk väldigt förstående.
Det blir ett problem i bolagsbygge och omorganisation och allt när det känns som att man inte är ärlig eller det känns som att det finns en annan agenda.
Och vi som grundar i bolaget, vi har alltid återinvisserat allting i bolaget, vi har aldrig tagit ut någon större vinst ifrån det.
Till och med när vi tog in kapital så satte vi in varenda krona i bolaget för att vi tror på bolaget långsiktigt.
Och det är också en väldigt viktig del.
Hade man haft en kultur som vissa kulturbolag har, att det snabbt handlar om att ta ut sina pengar eller snabbt tjäna en kova på det, då hade det nog varit något annat.
Drivkraften hade då varit ekonomiska, inte det vi vill bygga tillsammans.
Det har ju varit drivkraften för både oss grundare men också de som jobbar här.
Vi vill bygga någonting fantastiskt som vi är stolta över.
Men det känns relativt tydligt som att den stora grejen när ni behövde bromsa ner var att säga upp personal.
Det låter som den stora tyngden.
Det andra pratar du inte så mycket om.
Givetvis drog ni ner på viss marknadsföring, ni gick ur vissa länder.
Men det känns inte som en emotionell koppling.
Nej, jag tror att jag, absolut.
Det är klart man gjorde andra justeringar också.
Man kopplade bort marknad och hit och dit.
Men det är ingenting som...
Vi har som vision att bygga ett globalt nischbrand som är bäst på det vi gör globalt.
Om det tar 10, 2 eller 8 år, det struntar jag i.
Men vi ska dit.
Däremot att se upp personal handlar lite om att bryta relationer.
Och att man inte ses varje dag.
Det var mycket tuffare mentalt.
Det andra får ta det tiden den tar.
Du sa nischbrand här.
När jag skrev frågor till dig, så försökte jag hitta på vilken nisch ni var i.
Och jag kunde inte riktigt komma på ordet, men du sa nischen recovery tech.
Det har jag aldrig hört förut men det låter jävligt.
Det låter bra.
Jag gillar det ordet.
Det är på svenska återhämtningstechnologi.
Det är inte lika sexigt.
Vad ingår?
För jag är lite intresserad av hur ni jobbar med...
Nu hoppar jag litegrann här.
Men jag är lite intresserad av hur ni jobbar med era vertikaler och era olika produkter och vad ni tar fram.
För att från början så massagekudden som heter något annat och den här pistolen, det är väldigt logiskt i någon samma nisch.
Och sen har ni tagit fram lite träningsutrustning som har fyllt med vatten som också säkert har något annat namn.
Och vad ligger inom ert område och vad ligger inte inom ert område?
Jättebra fråga.
Det handlar om att hitta våra vertikaler och vad vi jobbar med.
Just nu så har vi recovery tech, alltså återrövningsteknik som nummer ett.
Och det är egentligen elektroniska tekniska produkter som hjälper till med återrövning på ett och annat vis.
Det är vår huvudnisch.
Sen har vi för att komplettera det så har vi också träningsprodukter.
Så vi har ju allt från gummiband till flowtanks med de här vattenträningstankarna som är ett innovativt, roligt sätt att träna.
Sen har vi även yogaprodukter som man kan använda för det.
Och grunden är någonstans, vi har gjort ett väldigt stort jobb nu, vi har försökt identifiera vår målgrupp och den personen.
Och det vi pratar om är att vi vill hitta produkter som passar vår kunds livsstil.
Och sen vill vi jobba runt det med vertikaler.
Så det kommer komma mycket spännande vertikaler och produkter framåt.
För det är en del av vår strategi, att hitta saker som faktiskt passar inom vår kunds livsstil.
Och just nu så är det ju fokus nummer ett på återhämtningen.
Hur kan vi ta fler sätt att bättre återhämta sig?
Det är det absolut primära.
Får du avslöja någonting?
Nej.
Nej men det är ju, vi kan väl säga såhär enkelt såhär, vi har ju identifierat våra kunder, de lever ett aktivt liv och strävar efter att leva ett aktivt liv.
Det är liksom grunden.
Och de är kvalitetsorienterade, de är lite nerdiga i det de gör, de vill ju läsa på.
Så inom den nischen ska vi hitta produkter som passar här.
Det kan vara alltifrån att vi har flowpression, lufttryckskompressionsbyxor nu.
Jag tänkte säga det för det är ju en lite nerdig produkt som passar en viss typ av människor.
Väldigt, den har vi ju sålt till väldigt många av allsvenska toppklubbarna och absoluta eliten.
Men också alltifrån frisörer eller folk som står upp mycket i arbetet.
Jag älskar den också.
Beredda det segmentet, hitta en mindre, lättare produkt av den.
Vi är bäst i världen på massage just nu, när det kommer till massage flow pillow, när det kommer till flow feet, just fotmassören.
Beredda det segmentet fler sätt.
Specificera olika områden som man kan behandla.
Så det blir en väldigt bred produktbräddning, men grunden är fortfarande tekniska produkter som hjälper till.
Vi tror att tekniken är en del av lösningen, och vi tror att det kommer vara väldigt mycket som händer där de närmaste åren.
Och där vill vi ligga längst fram.
Är det så ni tänker att, om ni ska ta fram en ny produkt, ni kikar på kunden, ser vad det är för kund, och funderar på, vad kan vi få in för nytta i den här?
För vi är ju lite barnsliga, vi jobbar ju lite på andra sättet.
Vi ser en produkt vi tycker om och säger att det här vill vi ha.
Så vi jobbar väldigt luststyrt, och så här, ja det här är en guldig stång, den verkar cool, det här ska vi köra på.
Sen om våra kunder vill ha den här, I don't know, vi testar det igen.
Jag ska inte sticka under solen med att det här, ibland så vill man hitta någonting innan det finns, eller innan någon vet vad de vill ha.
Och det är ju det absolut bästa, det är ju guldvärt.
Men det sker parallellt skulle jag säga, både och samtidigt.
Vi frågar våra kunder då vad de tror att ni vill ha.
Och ibland får man superidéer, men det är också så att ibland blir det väldigt styrt av det de har köpt tidigare.
Och det gäller att jobba på alla sätt samtidigt.
Jag har ju satt som mål i år att vi ska släppa så många produkter att vi i alla fall misslyckas med en.
Så att man sänker ribban så att man vågar vara lite galen.
Och sen måste man kanske inte tillverka så mycket av produkten första gången.
Man testar och ser hur den tas emot.
För jag tror att när vi släppte vår första flowgan så var det inte många som visste att de ville ha det.
Sen blev det en supersuccé ändå.
Finns det något bolag ni tittar på för att få inspiration?
Eller finns det någon speciell person hos er som är den innovativa?
Eller vem är det som tar fram produkter?
Det är ett teamjobb.
Jag tror att vi alla är väldigt intresserade.
Vi gör allt ifrån att vi åker på mässor.
Både i Asien och Kina och i Europa.
För att hitta de senaste trenderna och se vad som finns.
Vi jobbar tajt med flera fabriker.
Sen är vi alla ganska nerdiga i det här.
Det är mycket att skicka saker till varandra som man hittar eller kommer på idéer.
Jag tycker att de bästa idéerna egentligen kommer från den riktiga innovationen.
I alla fall för min egen del.
Det kommer när man upptäcker någonting, man tolkar det fel.
Man tycker att det är skitsmart.
Sen tänker man att det här borde vi göra.
Sen tänker man att det här finns inte, jag tänkte fel.
Och så har man en idé som man kan jobba vidare på.
Men en av våra medgrundare är produktutvecklingsansvarig.
Så vi har en som har det praktiska ansvaret för det.
Men jag tycker att produkten är larvigt kul.
Det är det roligaste.
Det är väl något som jag hoppar tillbaka till och försöker hjälpa och bistå med nu.
Trots att du ska hålla med i makroperspektivet nu så är du inne och grotta lite i...
Absolut.
Vi testar extremt mycket produkter.
När vi får in samplar så får vi ofta stora kartonger fyllda med väldigt mycket spännande grejer.
Jag är först där och vill titta och pilla.
Och har lärt mig att packa upp det försiktigt och lägga tillbaka det.
Så att det inte är kaos när han kommer tillbaka.
Jag vet också att du har pratat lite om att ni ville bli ett riktigt bolag.
Ni gjorde en stor genomlysning av bolaget och gick igenom alla processer och sånt där.
Och sen så hör man ju dig prata, då är det ju fortfarande lite entreprenörigt.
Man vill in och peta lite grann där.
Absolut, det finns en produktansvarig, men det är ändå du som ska in och peta och kika och ha kul.
Är ni ett riktigt bolag?
Jag tror att man blir vuxen flera gånger i livet.
Så blir man ett riktigt bolag väldigt många gånger också.
Och vi har ju blivit mycket mer tydligare på ansvarsområden och den biten, vi vill ju inte döda det entrepreniella.
Så det handlar om hur bygger vi en struktur, men vi ändå skapar frihet för innovation.
Och just nu är vi på en ganska bra plats där.
Det är lite, om man ska vara ärlig, tack vare också att vi fick in två personer i styrelsen när vi gjorde investeringsrundan, som har varit ett fantastiskt bollplank till mig och pratat om hur bygger man ett bolag som är skalbart över sikt och där du kanske kan ta semester och vara iväg utan att bolaget faller.
Och det har ju verkligen blivit en förändring där det är tydligare ansvarsområden.
Sen får man vara där och hjälpa till och tycka och känna och liksom ha det lustdrivna.
Men i slutändan så är man ju ansvarig för sitt område.
Och det tror jag är väldigt viktigt.
Vad skulle du säga att ni har, om man tar allt detta som ni har gått igenom, både med den extrema tillväxten och den dippen och nu återkomsten så att säga.
Vad kan du ta med dig från den perioden som du känner att det här gör vi jävligt bra och det här ska vi slopa.
Jag tror att det är fokus på det viktigaste.
Vad är det viktigaste för er?
Det viktigaste för oss är kvalitiprodukt.
Det är nummer ett.
Det kan vi aldrig tumma på.
Sen kommer kunden.
Kvaliteten mot hantering av kund.
Och sen det sista är att vi gör rätt saker.
Det är rätt partnerskap, rätt delar.
Vi är ett ungt gäng.
Vi alla tycker det är väldigt kul.
När vi hade som mest att göra det året som vi även tog in pengar och där vi faktiskt brände mest pengar.
Det året samarbetade vi med mer än hälften av alla allsvenskar klubbar.
Det var extremt lustigt.
Vi hade inte resurser, tillgänglighet eller möjlighet att följa upp eller göra ordentligt.
Men vi gjorde så mycket saker på en gång.
Det var superkul.
Det är någonting man kan göra.
Jag tror att man ska dra ut svängarna lite när det är en högkonjunktur och det går bra.
För det är viktigt för kulturen att vi hade platser till fotbollsmatch och vi fick göra roliga saker.
Men sen när det är en ekonomisk sväng då får man nog vara realistisk och säga vi kanske väljer ett samarbete som är mer strategiskt.
Inte lika lustdrivet.
Och så ser man till att man gör det ordentligt.
Så vi har ett mått och nu pratar om färre men värre.
Att vi har blivit bättre på att tacka nej till saker.
Jag älskar det uttrycket.
Färre men värre.
Okej.
Och min roll mycket mer är att säga nej till saker.
Vilket ibland kan kännas tråkigt, men i slutändan är ju folk så mycket nöjda när man kan faktiskt göra klart saker ordentligt.
Det tror jag när det gick som bäst också, när vi växte som bäst kan man väl säga.
Då var det också så att man kände att man inte kan göra saker riktigt så bra som man ville, men det gick ändå.
Då är det okej.
Men sen när det är en tuffare ekonomisk tid och man inte riktigt gör det som man vill, då är det inte lika kul.
Nu har vi verkligen färre men värre.
Det är en av de viktigaste delarna tror jag, vad som har fått oss att komma ut och vara ett bättre bolag efter två år av stålbad.
Det du nämner är ju ganska hårt kopplat till kvalitet.
Du nämner både kvalitet på produkt och kvalitet mot kunder som de primära kunderna.
Sen pratade du om samarbeten som ni har, ett gäng olika väldigt fina samarbeten och ni har haft otaliga samarbeten genom åren.
Allt det ligger lite mer åt premium hållet.
Ni har ju fortfarande en relativt billig produkt som fortfarande är en, jag gissar att ni säljer en anseendly made över julafton.
Den sortens produkt som ändå passar för en julklapp.
Har ni funderat på att ta sjukt mycket mer betalt?
Jo men det hade kanske varit det sättet många hade gjort när det blev tuffare ekonomiska tider.
Men när marginalen läckte ner, man ska inte glömma att konsumenten fick mindre i plånboken också.
Och vi inom vårt segment...
Ni verkar ha en hel del kunder inom Atletvärlden och den högpresterande och de är lite mindre priskänsliga.
De är väldigt mycket mindre priskänsliga.
Och när det är i vårt segment så är vi ju mest premium, vi har ju den bästa produkten.
Och jag skulle säga att vi ligger inte högst prismässigt.
Men det är också för att vi har en så stor del av vår egen försäljning är det du ser.
Vilket gör att direkt till slut kunde vi har vår hemsida.
Att återförsäljare inte är lika involverad i den.
Det gör ju att vi har möjlighet att inte ha lika höga priser baserat på den kvaliteten vi har.
Men jämför man oss mot många andra bolag så tror jag att vi har lagt en ganska mindre marginalstruktur på för att kunna leverera den kvaliteten på produkten.
Och sen är det ju kul så här, i Sverige så är det ju precis vem som helst som kan köpa våra produkter.
För vi är så breda och välkända och folkliga här.
När vi kollar utomlands så är det precis som du säger.
Vi får ju ganska mycket stora ordrar från andra delar av Europa och världen.
Och ofta när vi går in så är det någon som spelar i en högre uppsatt klubb, om det är fotboll, basket eller någon annan sport.
Så utomlands så är vi ju ett mycket mer nischat proffsbrand.
Och där är det många som tycker vi är för billiga.
Ja men för ni har inte olika prisstrategier.
Nej det är vi faktiskt inte.
Och det är inget ni har tänkt på?
Nej, det har vi inte.
Så vi har tänkt att man ska sälja produkter med någon form av service och så vidare.
Men vi har ju ett sätt där vi har produkter i, nu har vi det tydligaste på Ruff Logan, bra bättre bäst.
När den billigaste är en instegsmodell som kostar en tusen lappen, medan den dyraste kostar fyra tusen just nu.
Jag ser ju gärna att vi har en modell som kostar sju åtta tusen.
Att vi faktiskt har den bästa och gör den ännu dyrare.
Och med andra ord ännu bättre.
Och sen har vi en i mitten modell som vi ofta säljer mycket av.
Som är den som har alla de viktigaste funktionerna av den stora modellen.
Men kanske inte har vissa saker som är överflödig.
Den kanske inte behöver sex till åtta timmars batteritid när du använder den hemma.
För i snitt använder du din pistol tio minuter per gång.
Då räcker det kanske med en, två, tre timmar batteritid.
Så det handlar mycket om att ha någonting för alla nivåer.
Men jag tycker ju det är otroligt kul att få jobba mot eliten.
Och att få leverera produkter till några världens bästa atleter.
Men jag tycker ju det är minst lika kul att sälja till någon som berättar att de går på gym och har varit spända i sätet eller länryggen eller axlarna har haft problem och inte kan leka med sina barn.
Och sen så får man ett mejl och säger att helt plötsligt så har de rörligheten tillbaka och de har blivit av med sin stela axel.
Jag tycker det är minst lika värmande.
Vet du någonstans hur den fördelningen ser ut, hur redan snittkund ser ut?
Hur mycket är mot privat kund, hur mycket är mot företag, hur mycket är mot atlet kontra pensionärer som sitter på ålder och runt hennes hem?
De flesta sträber efter ett aktivt liv.
Sen är vad ett aktivt liv är väldigt odefinierat.
Men vi brukar säga att det finns tre triggers.
Jag kan börja med en enkla fråga om privat företag.
När man är 90-plussigt i privatpersoner.
Okej.
Så det är den stora marknaden.
Sen brukar vi säga att det finns tre triggers egentligen för att köpa våra produkt.
Det ena är den vi jobbar väldigt aktivt mot marknadsföringsmässigt vid varumärket runt det och det kallar vi performance and recovery.
Du köper en produkt för att prestera bättre och påskynda din återhämtning.
Mycket atleter, folk som tränar hårt, man vill lägga in ett extrapass i veckan.
Man ser till att man helt enkelt har den återhämtning man har.
Sen har vi smärtlindring.
Och det är ju det andra då, triggern.
Och då är det ofta att man har ett problem.
Det kan vara att man har problem med lämndryggen, man kan ha en vad som blir stel, man kanske har en fot som man börjar få kändning i, hålfoten, det kan vara falska ischas.
Och då köper man en produkt för att lösa det problemet.
Och sen sist men inte minst har vi den här wellnesskänslan.
Folk som köper produkten för att det känns bra.
Och det är den minsta målgruppen.
De flesta köper för att de vill antingen leverera bättre, prestera bättre, eller har ett behov för att de har ett problem de vill lösa.
Och mellan dem så är det ungefär 40-40 och sista är runt 20.
Ja, men det känns ungefär logiskt.
Det är nästan så om man tolkar varumärket på något sätt.
Jag tror att jag alltid tänkte på det som ett rehab-märke från början, men det är ju för att jag är invand i Flow Pillow.
Nu har jag lärt mig ordet här.
Och sen börjar man lära sig det här andra, okej.
Vad brinner ni själva mest för vilken, för nu har ni tagit in de här, vad kallar du de här, pressure kompressions...
Flow-pression.
Ja, flow-pression.
Och ni har tagit fram den här flow-water-tanks, säger jag rätt, ja, flow-tank.
Så det är ändå lite mer mot den aktiva.
Hur tänker ni på, vilken riktning vill företaget vara?
Vill ni fortsätta balansera här eller finns det någon...
Det tycker jag är intressant för att säga, vi har förmånen att jobba och sälja till många världens bästa atleter.
Vi har haft partnerskap med alltifrån Alpinas skidlandslaget till olympiska truppen, till massa andra bra klubbar.
Nu jobbar vi väldigt tajt med Stockholm Marathon till exempel.
Och vår bild egentligen, vi ska se till att vi jobbar med de som är absolut bäst i världen på det de gör.
De som har den strävan, de som dagligen utmanar sig pusha sig.
Och sen ska vi ta den läxan vi gör där och sedan ska vi leverera den tydligt så att även de som strävar efter att bara nå sin fulla potential kan nå dit.
Och en potential kan vara att man kanske ska springa ett halvmarathon, man kanske ska bänka 100 kilo eller man kanske bara ska leka med barnen.
Det är ens egna förutsättningar som säger det.
Och alla har ju olika röringetteringar till det.
Men när tekniken är där den är så är det för oss ganska lätt att göra en produkt som är tillräckligt bra för de bästa, men tillräckligt enkel för allihopa.
Och det var lite grundidén till bolaget när vi grundades.
För då hade vi jobbat både med, vi hade sett den här hemtekniksmassage marknaden som var mycket tv-shop.
Ska man vara ärlig så var det mycket skit på marknaden.
Va?
Ja, det är trot eller ej.
You don't say.
Ja, och det var liksom larvigt.
Saken gick sönder.
Och sen så fanns det de här produkterna man sålde till fysioterapeuter och knapprapater.
Jag kom ihåg att jag pratade med någon som var en superduktig uppfinnare som gjorde sina proffsprodukter, så stoppade han in en motor som kostade 100 gånger mer än vad han hade behövt göra.
Han hade beställt den från USA, från ett bolag som hade jobbat mot NASA.
Jag frågade varför han hade den här, och han sa att det är på leasing, så det spelar ingen roll vad den kostar.
Och det är mindsetet med att de ena sparar på kostnader och gör dåliga produkter, de andra gör så bra att de bara är bäst med kanske onödiga och bra.
Och hittar något där i mitten, de hittar spexoteknik som är anpassad för en vanlig människa eller någon med en tydlig sträva någonstans, samtidigt som de är så pass bra att de faktiskt gör jobbet.
Och där har vi hittat något som funkar väldigt fint.
Och jag tror det är därför många massörer, sjukvimaster och napparpater själva rekommenderar oss.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Vad brinner vi mest för?
Vi är ett ungt gäng, vi alla tycker det är kul och att vara aktiva.
Det kicklar lite extra när man kan pusha sig själv lite mer.
En anledning till att jag tror att jag och många andra tränar det är att man får ett väldigt mycket större behov av våra produkter om man tränar.
Jag var på gymmet nu förra veckan och sprang i intervaller.
Det var lite ouppvärmt dumt nog.
Men så fort man höjer tempo så känner jag att det händer något baksida lår.
Sen får testa de nya produkterna på det.
Det är något väldigt roligt.
Så jag tror inte, och det kicklar till lite extra när man får vara inne i träningsvärlden.
Sen tycker jag att det är kul att hjälpa folk som har problem också.
Men det kicklar lite extra när det handlar om träning.
Jag fattar precis.
Jag jobbade som PT i många år.
Det är klart det är kul att hjälpa folk med sitt liv och det är roligare för dem men det är lite roligare och lite häftigare att jobba med atleter.
Det är också kul.
Ja men när man kan stå med någon som har ett OS-guld och pratar med dem och förstår deras på och sen märker att vi är det bästa alternativet.
Det är en häftig känsla.
Har det alltid varit er marknadsföringsnisch?
Ni jobbar ju mycket med lag, eller vad jag ska kalla det då, eller klubbar kanske.
Hur mycket rör ni er mot det hållet kontra att jobba med TikTok-influencers bara för att sätta totalt andra sidan?
Vi har ju nästan aldrig jobbat med influencers.
Nej.
Utan vi har alltid jobbat med atleter.
Nej men vi tycker att vi behöver inte det i vår nisch.
Det finns extremt mycket influencers och den branschen kanske också är lite mer snabbrörlig.
Vi ser ofta till att vi hittar folk som genuint och gillar våra produkter och användning för det.
Sen kan det vara någon influencer som lever ett aktivt liv och det blir en supermatch, alltså superfine, ingen konstighet med det.
Men det finns ett stort behov av atleter för våra produkter.
Vi får så mycket samarbetsförslag att vi är sällan att höra av oss utåt om det snart hittar hand om det som kommer.
Sen har man lärt känna många duktiga atleter genom åren och varit med på deras resa och bidragit med produkter och haft olika kampanjer ihop och gjort grejer.
Ja, jag tänker på att ni har en relativt liten produktbas.
Jag säger inte att det bara är en produkt, men om man jämför med en vanlig aktör som säljer direkt mot konsument så är det ju vanligare att man kanske försöker hålla lite fler SKUs eller unika produkter då för att kunna få den här merförsäljningen.
Jag vet inte hur många unika produkter ni har men kanske en 25.
Ja det ligger väldigt nära där upp mot SK.
Yes, jag har gjort en research.
Och hur jobbar ni med merförsäljning när det är så pass liten möjlighet att pusha nya produkter?
Jättebra fråga och det handlar ju väldigt mycket om att de här olika triggers, se vad det är för behov.
Här säljer vi kanske en flow gun till någon först, så upptäcker de att den funkar superbra.
Vilken är er instegsprodukt?
Vilka är de i särklass, mest första köpta produkterna?
Flow pillow heat, vår massage kudde.
Och den har sålt hur många genom åren vet du det?
Oj, nej väldigt många, väldigt, väldigt många.
Alltså jag skulle lyssa upp mot 50 till 100 000.
Så den är ju en stor säljare.
Och det är också den bredaste produkten.
Alltså vem som helst mår bra av en massage.
Och här har du en massage kudde som helt plötsligt kan massera allt från lår, vader, axlar, nackor, fötter.
Och det är ju en sån klassisk instegsprodukt att man börjar där så märker man, oj nu har jag masserat upp min vad men jag känns lite stel i foten.
Jättebra, då tar jag en flow fit istället.
Men det har ju varit en utsvars...
Kan ni se den köpresan eller är det mer en så här vill ni att köpresan ska se ut?
Nej, det går att se.
Däremot är ju varje köpresa unik och vi ser ju vissa typer av mönster.
Men det är ju en utmaning för oss att vi inte har så pass många olika produkter.
Och det gäller ju att se till att de som köper en produkt blir så pass nöjda att de köper en produkt till någon de tycker om.
Och det är ju en väldigt stor del av vår kundresa också.
Du köper en produkt, antingen så breddar du ditt egna utbud med att komplettera med fler produkter.
Men det finns också en väldigt stor typ av kund som köper en produkt i sig själv, tycker om den väldigt mycket.
Kanske har någon hemma och säger på besök, någon familjemedlem, de får prova produkten.
De märker att den är väldigt härlig.
Sen köper de en till produkt och ger bort.
Så våra produkter är ju väldigt gårdvåndgördorienterade.
Och du sa ju Linnon, jul.
Ja, så jul är ju en jättebra period för oss.
För vi ligger ju kanske i det här övre spannet med vad man köper julklappar.
Vår produkt kostar ju ofta mellan 1000 till 9000.
Och det brukar ju vara någonstans där en julklapp kan ligga till någon man tycker om.
Och hur gör man när...
Jag hoppar här lite grann.
Det känns lite som att jag har suttit här i en boxningsmatch med dig.
Normalt sett när man sitter i en sån här intervju så är det en ganska linjär kurva och man följer vägen framåt.
Här känns det som att vi bara har suttit och slängt in frågor och jag har absolut ingen aning om vad som kommer ut på andra sidan.
Vi har inte haft någon kronologisk följ där utan det har varit ner i detaljer.
Men det känns ändå helt underbart.
Jag bara längtar efter att få höra den sen.
Det är så kul för att du sa ganska tydligt att du har varit med i andra poddar till mig och du har ju berättat din historia kronologiskt.
Så vi gör någonting annat och jag känner att jag vill ändå ligga och följa.
För jag har ingen aning om var vi här i tiden längre.
Det är ju supertrevligt i alla fall.
Ni jobbar ju ganska mycket eget, ni jobbar med egna marknadsföring och sånt där.
Hur mycket av det ni säljer, säljer ni via andra leverantörer?
Och hur ser ni på de samarbetena?
Jag brukar säga att vi har ju fått att leka lite kronologi här ett tag innan tiden.
Så vi grundades i 2016.
Och från början så var vi ju ett eventbolag till stor del.
Vi upptäckte väldigt fort efter vårt första event på Lidinge Loppet.
Det fanns en fantastisk möjlighet att stå vid målgången på olika lopp, erbjuda våra produkter som när folk har sprungit, cyklat eller gjort något annat, och så får de testa det när de är som mest mottagliga.
Så från 2016 till 2018 så var vi väldigt mycket ut på events.
Det var vår primära intäktskanal.
Sen 2018 så satsade vi mycket på e-handeln, och nästan ututslutande sålde vi via e-handel under pandemintiden.
Det som hänt det senaste året är en stor del av bolagsmognaden.
Vi har gått från event till e-handel till att nu vara mer av ett brand.
Vi är mer och mer öppna upp för återförsäljare.
Det är en stor del av strategin nu att vi hittar rätt partners att jobba med.
Okej, ni har inte plockat hem försäljningen utan snarare öppnat upp?
Ja, snarare öppnat upp och specificerat specifika produkter till vissa återförsäljare som vi kan jobba med.
Det för oss öppnar till att vi kan fokusera på det vi vill göra och det är ju produktutveckling.
Skiljer sig den strategin i Sverige kontra utomlands?
Jobbar ni mer med återförsäljare utomlands än i Sverige till exempel?
Nej, det är ganska jämnt faktiskt.
I just Norden som sin helhet.
Sen har vi i vissa marknader, till exempel Frankrike, säljer vi en hel del till.
Där har vi en distributör.
Så den distributören har exklusivitet på den marknaden.
Så har egna återförsäljare.
Men jag skulle säga generellt sett utomlands, utanför Norden så är vi mycket mer specialistföretag i att vi är mycket mer nischade mot eliten.
Och det är ingenting aktivt som vi jobbar för, utan det är någonting som händer naturligt.
Våra produkter sprids väldigt organiskt inom den världen.
Okej, så det skiljer ingenting i marknadsföring, det skiljer ingenting i hur det har bara blivit så att kunden ser ut?
Ja, det har nog varit så mycket rekommendationer och jag tror...
Kan ju vara för att ni började på mässor med massage i Sverige också.
Jaja, och så här, jag vet ju till exempel, vi hade, vi har sålt ganska mycket till Milan till exempel som fotbollsklubben, och jag vet ju att det fanns ju två svenskar som spelade.
Jag älskar att du förklarar, om någon lyssnar på den här fucking podden och inte vet vad Milan betyder när du säger Milan, och vi måste förklara att det är en fotbollsklubb.
Till och med jag som inte ens tittar på fotboll vet jag.
De hade ju två svenskar där som spelade för några år sedan.
Det är en av liksom, som vissa kallar den riktiga kungen.
Och jag vet ju att det är personer som har haft våra produkter.
Och det är ofta så det har spridit sig, att det har varit folk med inflytande och därför tror jag att fotbollen blev en ganska stort fos utomlands.
Att det har varit folk som man har sett upp till inom sin klubb som har haft våra produkter och sen har man blivit köpa in det till klubben.
Och även de här atleterna, det är ingenting ni reachar ut till.
Du sa förut att folk kontaktar er, brukar även de sprida er naturligt så att säga.
Ja, det är väldigt nice och det är därför jag tror vi jobbar mycket med atleter.
För att de gillar de produkten, kommer de delar för det är en del av deras livsstil.
Och det är ju en väldigt bra affär för oss.
Och ni har ingen liten grupp med de här atleterna som ni, vad är det ni saknar, vad finns det för produkter här som vi kan ta fram för att verkligen få den spridningen i den gruppen.
Ja, vi brukar be om mycket feedback.
I produktutvecklingen så är ju ett av våra stora leder att vi är duktiga på att vara mjuka mot både kunder men också mot elitatleter och folk inom branschen, alltså fysioterapeuter och så vidare.
Och vi brukar fråga dem vad tror ni nästa sak blir, vad tycker ni saknas, hur kan vi utveckla det här.
Och det är ju en sak som det har varit guld värt för oss att kunna få den kompetensen till oss från några Sveriges bästa tränare, Sveriges bästa atleter och verkligen använda det för att vidareutveckla.
Finns det någon sån där produkt som ni har fått tips om som ni bara känner, den där borde vi inte ha tagit in, det var en skitprodukt eller det liksom flög inte kommersiellt?
Det finns ju produkter vi har haft som vi har tagit bort, som jag ändå tror på men som inte tajmade i resan.
Jag gillar att du fortfarande känner viss kärlek för dem, det är så här nej nej, släng dem bara.
Vi hade ju en produkt som heter Flow Roller Vive.
Jag vet faktiskt vilken det var.
Ja och den var ju fantastisk, men jag tror i det läget så hade vi så mycket fokus på det som flög på ett annat sätt.
Vi sålde så mycket mer massagepistoler via Flow Guns då än vad vi gjorde av Flow Roller Vive.
Så vi faktiskt kasserade den produkten, men jag tror fortfarande den hade passat i vår arsenal.
Men då började vi ett utvecklingsprojekt som var på i nästan två år, där vi tog fram en väldigt liten boll som skulle vibrera.
Problemet med det här var att när den var kvar så kostade den så mycket till slut konsument att det kändes som att ingen kommer att vilja betala och det här är faktiskt en sak som är lite tråkig i vår produktlinje.
När en produkt är mindre, alltså till storleken, så tycker folk att den ska kosta mindre.
Så det finns liksom en utmaning i att göra det här och det är därför att teknologiska är ändå viktigt att lyfta fram.
Att det kan vara en liten produkt med mycket teknik som ändå är världsutpris.
Och när vi hade en så liten boll som hade en väldigt bra funktion så var det liksom svårt att hitta en villighet att betala för.
Jag kan köpa kundens tanke för man tänker att det är en boll som vibrerar.
Jag kan inte betala 2 000 för det.
Men sen finns det ju såklart en tanke bakom och allt sånt där.
Men jag köper ändå hur kunden resonerar.
I egentligen är det ju precis samma sak som en foam roller som vibrerar bara att det är lite mer foam på en foam roller.
Men folk var ändå vilja att betala en dubbla för en foam roller kontra en liten boll.
Så det ligger ju ändå någon logik i det fast det blir lite roligt när man vänder den bakåt.
Om vi tar den här massagspistolen som du precis nämnde, eller flogan får vi säga, vi får marknadsföra så hårt vi kan.
Snyggt.
Det var ju en helt absurd hype kring den ett tag.
Jag vet inte, på varenda mässa man gick på så stod det ju sådana här människor som bara körde dem i ryggen på en och visade upp.
Det var ganska häftigt.
Hur har försäljningen av den sett ut genom åren?
Säljer den fortfarande?
Och är det fortfarande en grej?
Absolut, den säljer fortfarande jättebra.
Sen hade det ju en peak under pandemin där.
Så mycket e-handel hade.
Det som har hänt nu är väl att när vi började med återhämtningsprodukter, då var det ingen som pratade om återhämtning kopplat till träning, för det var lite töntigt.
Sen när massagepistoler kom då så blev det helt plötsligt häftigt.
Så det var många som försökte haka på det.
Det kom flera bolag som bara sålde massagepistoler.
Det var tre, fyra svenska bolag som var i varierad kvalitet, som var mycket ut på mässor och konkurrerade.
Nu tror jag att ingen av dem finns kvar, men jag ska vara ärlig.
Men de var ju där och hjälpte till att bygga hypen runt det.
För när man såg många aktörer undrar man vad det var i det här.
Nu tror jag att det har gått lite mer till behovsförsäljning.
Har man ett behov så vet man vad som finns.
Man vet var det är och hur man hittar den.
Och vi har ju vunnit i princip alla bäst i test vi varit med i med den produkten.
Så jag tror att en stor del av den försäljningen inom det segmentet nu kommer till oss.
Det finns inte så många andra bra alternativ.
På europeisk bas inom vårt segment så finns det ju det finns ju egentligen en europeisk konkurrensklass.
Det är Burer som är med lite på home-hållet.
Och sen så har vi två amerikanska aktörer som är väldigt duktiga på det de gör.
Men det är väldigt amerikanskt och det kanske inte hänt super mycket på produktutvecklingen på senaste.
Jag kan tycka just den produkten är intressant för att från en utrustningsleverantörssida så när det hypades upp så tog ju folk hem containervis med det.
Det brandades ju upp i alla varumärken.
Vi tog också hem en sån variant och jag vet att alla våra grossister gjorde samma sak.
Och sen vet jag att det tog ett år och sen stod det liksom containerar fulla med sådana.
Har ni jobbat någonting med att köpa upp konkurrenter eller folk som går in i er segment?
Nej ingenting faktiskt.
Så som du sa, det är ju många som försvinner på vägen.
Det är ju många som vill in i träningsutrustning men det är en svår...
Det är en mycket svårare bransch än man tror tror jag.
Är det något ni har funderat på att det där är något vi vill in i?
Nej, det var ju när någon höll på att vika av som vi hade enklare samtal.
Men någonstans kom vi fram till att vi ska fokusera på vårt, vi ska stilla ett långsiktigt perspektiv, vi ska göra det bra.
Det kommer alltid komma lyckosökare och det är en naturlig del när det finns en hype i någonting.
Det kommer folk som är med på den hypen, sen försvinner de och gör någonting annat.
Så det är ganska många aktörer som har kommit så speciellt e-handelsmässigt som sen gör det ett tag när det är så mest hype, sen försvinner de.
Vi har lite långsiktigare perspektiv där.
Och det är ju en grind.
Vår vision och vårt arbete är att vi alltid ska vara bäst i vårt produktsegment.
Och det skulle jag säga att vi är 95 av 100 dagar.
Sen ibland kommer det en konkurrent eller någon annan som gör någonting som är väldigt bra.
Det måste man vara ödmjuk att säga till.
Ibland kan det vara något annat som levererar som är bra.
Men då är vårt jobb så snabbt som möjligt att vara bättre.
Och inte bara att vi själva säger det, för det är liksom enkelt sagt.
Utan att vi ser till att vi skickar ut våra produkter till väldigt många olika tester.
Som är oberoende och nu vann vi precis bäst i test på massagskuddar i Aftonbladet.
Vilket också är en produkt som har funnits i snart sju år och vidareutvecklats ett par gånger.
Helt plötsligt var det ett nytt uppsving.
För då är det en ny kundgrupp, alltså Aftonbladets läsare, som ser, oj det här är en massagskudde, det här kan den göra och flowlife är bäst.
Det är ju guld värt att hålla sig aktuell genom att vara med och testa där.
Men nej, jag vet inte.
Just nu har vi inte sett någon behov av att kika på och köpa upp på konkurrenter, utan vi håller fokus på oss själva.
Kan ni se någon sorts produkt eller kategori som trendar just nu, inte kanske specifikt på att någon gör ett test i en stortidning, utan mer så som massagbistol var och sedan blev någonting annat?
Kan ni se någonting nu?
Vad är det som är trendigt nu?
Ja, vi lanserade vår TENS i maj förra året.
Ja, just det.
Det har ju kommit mycket.
Och det intressanta med den är ju TENS är ju en teknik som används väldigt länge, den är väldigt evidensbaserad.
I Sverige får de som föder ofta bli erbjudna att hyra hem en eller låna en.
Kan du inte förklara vad TENS är?
TENS är alltså elektrisk muskelstimulans.
Det funkar på det sättet att du har två olika sätt att använda.
Det ena är att du överbelastar nervsystemet, vilket ju funkar som en smärtaplokad.
Det gör att du faktiskt direkt när du använder den får du en upplevd mindre smärta.
Vilket är superhäftigt genom allt ifrån sträckningar, träningsverk, otroligt populär bland mensverk också.
Det finns många användningsområden.
Sen har du också det att du aktiverar muskeln.
Du får muskeln att spänna sig och kontrahera och dra ihop.
Det ökar blodcirkulationen, det är lätt att få spänningar.
Så du har väldigt mycket funktioner.
Du kan få det utskrivet från Länsningen till exempel om du har mycket problem med axlarna som leder till migrän och spänningsverk.
Så det är en otroligt häftig teknik.
Men den är starkt associerad med att du får det av en sjukgymnast eller någon inom vården som säger såhär ska du använda den, använd den bara såhär och sen är du klar.
Det vi gjorde då att vi tog den tekniken.
Vi gjorde den supersmidig så att den var enkel att placera vart man ville.
Sen tog vi fram en app tillsammans med några superduktiga sjukhusnaster och fysisk där vi anpassade program för olika användningsområden.
Så det gör egentligen att vi har idiot säkrat den kan man säga.
Att du ser exakt vart du ska placera den.
Du har ett program anpassat för det behovet du har och så blir det väldigt lätt att använda.
Det är en sån produkt som har varit fantastiskt att lägga till i kundstocken och blivit superväl mottagen.
Kan ni känna att folk är lite nervöa?
Nu, du sa ju att det är en beprövad teknik och jag vet att det fanns redan på tv-shoptiden det som du pratade om innan, men man körde den här mage...
Om vi säger att det där är version 0.001 så kanske detta är 20 versioner senare.
Men jag tycker ändå att folk kanske kan känna en viss oro kring att sätta elektriska stötar på sig själv.
Är det något ni behöver undervisa om?
Jag tror att det gäller att prova produkten i så fall för att det är en speciell känsla när man använder den.
Det är inte smärtsamt, de elektriska stötarna är så minimala att gå över en liten del.
Det är väldigt likt de elektriska impulserna som används för att styra kroppen.
Det gör vi via elektriska impulser.
Det är en lite speciell känsla.
I början är det lite ovant, men när man använder det ett tag börjar det bli väldigt skönt.
De flesta börjar kanske inte maxa upp det direkt.
Men absolut, det finns ju vissa som tycker det är lite läskigt.
Men det är inte som att det är ett oceärerlopp där vi skickar stötar i folk så att de inte kan gå.
Utan det är relativt små stötar som behövs för att få den effekten.
När du pratar om en ny produkt eller produktkategori på det här sättet, hur mycket av er utveckling omsättningsmässigt som företag skulle du säga drivs av nya produkter kontra nya marknader?
För att om ni har vissa basprodukter som, jag gissar att er företag är som alla andra företag, att det är 80 procent sales av basen och sen är det nya produkter.
Eller får ni nya hyper av de här nya produkterna eller?
Vart kommer tillväxten?
Det är precis det målet vi har satt i år faktiskt.
Att 20 procent av ökningen i år ska komma från nya produkter.
Det är ändå rätt kraftigt.
Ja verkligen.
Det kommer komma många roliga nyheter i år.
Vi har tidigare kanske haft ett synsätt på att vi försöker hitta en ny produkt som ska stå för 50 procent av omsättningen.
Att det ska vara en stor nysomprodukt.
Nu har vi kanske accepterat att vi ska ha produkter som står för 5 till 10 procent av omsättningen som är mer specificerade.
Så det kan komma en produkt som är anpassad för ett speciellt användningsområde där vi nu har produkter som är väldigt heltäckande.
Så det kommer vara supergul.
Och sen nya marknader.
Nej men i år så blir det faktiskt ett primärt fokus på Sverige, Norge och Danmark.
Där vi redan är ganska starka.
Vi har tidigare sålt ner Nederländerna.
Vi har jobbat en del och kollat på Tyskland.
Det är såklart superintressant marknad, men vi vill lägga det fokuset vi har på att ta fram de produkterna som kommer i år så bra som möjligt.
Och sen avvaktar vi med nya marknader till 2025.
Om vi tar den här resan som ni har haft här nu då, de senaste åren och allt det som som du snackar om här och har lärt er, kommer ni göra om den här, det är såklart svårt att säga.
Tror du att ni kommer göra om den här resan?
Ja men ni landar lite grann, ni kommer igång igen.
Tror du att ni skulle göra om en investeringsrunda i framtiden eller är det mer, ja nu har vi gjort det, vi har känt på detta, detta är en väg, nu har vi de här människorna i företag som vi vill känna, lära känna.
Jag är bara intresserad av hur man tänker.
Nej men jag tror att det är nog beroende på situation men ska man vara ärlig att det vi fick in med den här investeringsrundan har varit fantastiskt.
Det var såklart en anledning till att vi kunde ta ett år där vi kunde göra alla de här bolagsinvesteringarna trots att det var kris i världen och kunde acceptera att gå med förlust under ett år.
Det var för att vi hade investeringen.
Så de gjorde att vi kunde fortsätta bygga ett väldigt bra bolag.
Så det skulle man vara supertacksam för ekonomiska.
Men i grunden har vi också fått in fantastiska personer, som vi har varit väldigt engagerade.
Det jag skulle slänga med till alla som startar bolag eller driver bolag är absolut investering.
Pengarna är en del men människorna är mycket viktigare.
Se till att det är rätt personkemi.
Och det kan ju komma från att jag driver bolag med tre av mina väldigt nära vänner, är ju att se till att även investerare är delaktiga i bolaget.
Se till att det är folk du lyssnar på, du vill prata med, du vill lära dig av.
Och jag skulle aldrig ta in en investering från någon som jag inte kände att jag hade en bra person kemi med.
För de blir lite som att gifta sig med någon, man blir fast med dem.
Och jag skulle inte kunna vara gladare för att det tog precis de investerare vi hade nu för att det har varit fantastiskt engagemang och det har varit personer som genuint tror på det vi gör långsiktigt och inte har det här kortsiktiga målet med att man måste nå någonstans under ett visst år utan det handlar om att bygga ett fantastiskt bolag över tid.
Och gör vi det rätt så kommer allt annat falla på plats.
Jag tänkte nästan avsluta lite med, du nämnde dina tre delägare här, eller dina tre medgrundare får vi säga då.
Vad ska man säga, det finns ju ganska många experter som säger att man ska inte starta bolag med sina polare.
För att det går ju så där.
Men ni har ju ändå gått igenom rätt mycket ihop, fyra pers och alla fyra jobbar fortfarande här.
Ni pratar fortfarande med varandra, kanske tar en lunch ibland.
Till och med det, till och med umgås ganska mycket.
Alltså okej fortfarande, ja.
Det är galen och ibland, jag tror att det är skönt med att vara fyra personer det gör att alla har olika roller.
Jag tror att det var ganska bra att vi alla tog vår roll ganska fort i bolaget.
Sen så tror jag att det är jätteviktigt.
Det är klart att det finns perioder man blir irriterad på varandra.
Det finns också perioder där kanske en levererar bättre eller sämre än någon annan.
Jag tror att man måste ha förståelse för att vi är människor.
Man måste prata när det blir fel.
Och sen måste man se till att lösa saker tillsammans.
Att driva bolag med vänner är fantastiskt kul.
Men man måste nog ganska tidigt aligna vad man är ut efter.
Vår fördel är att vi alla är väldigt långsiktiga i det vi gör.
Det är ingen som har det här korta ekonomiska incitamentet av att vi måste göra någonting under ett visst antal år och sen casha ut.
Vi vill bygga ett fantastiskt bolag, det är vår drivkraft.
Och då funkar det väldigt bra.
För då har man det stora perspektivet, då blir de små detaljerna mindre utmanande.
Och det gäller att verkligen njuta av resan så gott det går.
Men fan, göra jobbet när det är tufft också.
Ja men du sa också att ni alla valde era roller ganska mycket från början.
Du har aldrig varit chefs om de rollerna.
Alltså det är ju klart och vi har ju hört ibland att det kanske jag och en till som båda tycker om och tycker lite mycket.
Och ibland tycker vi olika.
Men jag tror att det är viktigt att man får tycka olika och man får prata om det.
Men sen såhär, man kan inte gå och ha ingen av oss speciellt långsinta, vilket jag tror är väldigt bra.
Vi är ganska lättsamma så man kan ha en tuff diskussion och sen kan man släppa det.
Men nu har vi blivit mycket bättre på olika roller.
Men det är också en supersvår roll när man får in investerare som är superduktiga på liksom bolagsbygge och har varit på många stora bolag.
Och sen ska man sitta där och sen är man grundare av bolaget, liksom ägare.
Man sitter i styrelsen, man är vd och man är operativ.
Så helt plötsligt sitter man på fyra hattar samtidigt.
Och så är man alla personer samtidigt.
Det jag har fått lära mig är att man har olika uppgifter på olika roller.
De hade det häftiga i Chalmers skola för entrepreneurship.
Så hade de ett rum med hattar.
Och så fanns det alltså hattar i olika färger med en beskrivning vilken personlighetskaraktär man skulle ha där.
Ibland känner man sig så när man hoppar i olika roller.
Ja men jag förstår precis.
Jag tror det är viktigt, något jag har lärt mig som vd och grundare, ibland ska man, när man säger saker så kan man kanske säga vilken perspektiv man säger ifrån.
Man kommer med en åsikt, är det här jag som vd som säger det, eller är det här jag som bara har en åsikt som människa och kunde särskilja på det.
Och det är någonting jag har blivit bättre på min tiden, men som var svårare i början.
Och känner du att ni som team har gjort någon sorts gemensam utveckling i detta?
Att ni snackar om, nu närmar vi oss hundra miljoner här, och sen nästa steg är det här.
Vad behöver vi bli som personer i detta?
En person som jobbar med it när man slänger upp en tic-tale lösning med två produkter är ju en grej.
Det är en helt annan grej när du har x antal system i olika länder.
En ganska stor personlig utveckling som krävs i den, och kunskapsutveckling.
Ligger ni på varandra?
Stöttar ni varandra eller får varje person ta sitt område och göra?
Vi pratar väldigt mycket om att att ett av våra ledor är personlig och professionell utveckling och att det går hand i hand.
Jag försöker ibland se oss som ett lag tillsammans.
I ett lag hjälper man någon när de blir skadade, för ibland kommer det att hända att folk är skadade.
Men man ska också alltid se till att prestera.
Man ska se till att teama ihop för att tillsammans få varandra att prestera.
Det är väldigt viktigt.
Vi är ett ungt gäng.
Som ett ungt gäng så vet vi att vi måste ta den här tiden för att utveckla oss.
Och göra, ibland lägga den tiden själva för att bli bättre på det vi gör.
För att det går väldigt fort nu i tekniken och alltid från A1s infart.
Det är mycket som förändras väldigt fort.
Det gäller att alltid vara uppdaterad annars blir man efter.
Jag tänker också på hur man bibehåller företags, den goda företagskulturen när man är, om man är fyra grundare, och säger att man har åtta anställda utöver dem kanske, då är ju ändå 30 procent av arbetsstirkan grundare.
För att inte bli, att det är ni fyra som bestämmer och ni som blir eliten innan, eftersom ni har varje område nästan.
Hur gör man för att ändå få en god känsla bland kollegorna?
Så att de känner att vi faktiskt också har en say i utvecklingen.
De fanns för att vara i sina områden.
Man finns kvar därefter.
Allt det visuella.
Vi har en som är ansvarig för det, vi har en som är ansvarig för e-comm, och då är vi ansvariga för kundtjänst.
Jag tror det är viktigt att se att de är ansvariga för det.
Så får de komma på lösningar.
Sen kan man ha åsikter och tycka till.
Jag brukar ofta ha åsikter till krill, men sen brukar jag kolla på de och säga att det är de som bestämmer, enligt sitt område.
Och de har, jag tror att som ledare, så är det viktigt att sätta vissa typer av ramar för att veta vad man ska utvecklas inom.
Men sen ger de friheten inom de ramarna och faktiskt säga det som är viktigt.
Om man inte sätter de yttre förutsättningarna, då är det svårt för någon att vara kreativ.
Det är som att ge någon en tavla och säga att måla någonting.
Eller bara här är ett äpple, måla dig så här coolt och fint du kan.
Det blir lättare om du har någonting att utgå ifrån.
Och sätta de ramarna som ledare är viktigt också.
Ge dem en tydlig frihet.
Men jag tror att vi snarare hade lite för mycket frihet och för lite styrning.
Det har aldrig varit ett direkt problem.
Om man har en strukturell styrning, med de här tydliga ramarna, årsmål eller vår produktutvecklingsansvar är 20% av intäkter ska man få nya produkter, supertydligt.
Då vet man vad det innebär.
Då är det ut och hitta nya grejer.
Då behöver inte jag säga så mycket mer.
Om jag helt saknar grunder och barierar med ett blankkamm, då kommer jag vara tvungen att picka.
Då kommer jag vara tvungen att försöka trycka till dem innanför den strategin.
Men så länge grundförutsättningarna är tydliga så tror jag väldigt mycket på fejet i arbete.
Tror man behöver det för att vara motiverad.
Det låter sunt tror jag, det passar världen.
Jag tänker en liten sista fråga bara.
Vi har ju ganska många människor, aspirerande entreprenörer som vill in i träningsbranschen säger jag då, eftersom det är mest det jag fokuserar på.
Men vad var det du kallade din?
Recovery tech.
Jag bara gillar det ordet, fan vad det låter mäktigt.
Jag förstår att det ska ta över världen.
Men om man vill in i något av våra områden och faktiskt kunna göra sig själv lönsam där och inte bara bli en dagslända som säljer massagspistoler under ett år och sen försvinner.
Vad behöver man tänka på och vad behöver man göra annorlunda?
Det gäller ju att ha ett långsiktigt perspektiv.
Jag tror att hitta sina drivkrafter, varför man vill göra grejer.
Vill man bara göra någonting för att tjäna pengar så skulle man kanske göra någonting annat.
För då kommer man att tycka att det är kul ett tag och sen så fort man börjar möta motgångar så gör man någonting annat.
Så jag tror att det är viktigt att hitta sina drivkrafter.
Jag som driver bolag med andra skulle hitta någon att dela det med.
Gärna få in en partner eller någonting annat.
Och sätta på den tydlig men också rätt lös plan.
Jag tror mycket på att planer, men jag tror också på att djupplanerna så fort någonting annat händer.
För det går inte att förutspå vad som kommer att hända de första åren.
Och försöka inte förändra världen på en kafferast.
Ha ett långsiktigt perspektiv, var nöjd med att börja någonstans.
Så länge man tar ett steg i rätt riktning så är man på väg åt rätt håll.
Jag ser mycket mer utveckling i processen viktigare än delmålet.
Så länge man rör sig åt rätt håll hela tiden så är det framgång.
Fan vad insiktsfull du är.
Jag får tacka för ett fantastiskt samtal.
Jag skulle säga att detta var nästan en intervju för min skull.
Jag känner att jag fick ställa bara frågor som jag tycker är roliga.
Därför blev det lite hoppigare idag men det var fruktansvärt kul att få höra.
Ja du det var supertrevligt att prata.
Vi säger tack så mycket och hejdå.
Tack, tack.
På gymkompaniet är det ju så att jag är överlägset i sämst form.
Känner du också att alla dina kollegor är lite bättre?
Hehe, eller?
Cred Kristoffer, så all cred till honom.